[Music]
Okay. So now when you do
kokuho,
you're going to use
your yong aspect, his yong aspect, but
you can use the yong aspects of the
centrifugal and centripal energy. Okay?
And you can use one hand
via those forces to generate the
adhesion on the other hand. Okay. So
when we go to play
the
you got to just kind of watch out for
the mic. Okay. When we go to play the co
game, there's there's a stickiness.
There's a stickiness here. So
I'm not going to slip up. Okay. It's not
that I just parrying it to the inside
like that. I stick to it. Okay.
Does that
Does that make sense? Okay. So, let I
have I have his initial force. Do you
see that? I that I can use to
internalize to generate
the alchemical yong coming back. Okay.
But I can make sure that this hand is
not taking the energy off. Okay. So if I
like for example try to take that that
way, you see how it came off. Okay. I
have to use that this energy to keep
there's the weight that I want. Okay? Do
do you guys understand that? So, you
have to always feel
>> what what you want to happen and never
take it never take it off.
>> Okay? until you
until you you're like, "Oh, I I want to
disrupt with CoQ." Okay. But when we're
not working in grips, you have to do co
do from iiki. Does that make sense? So
when you when you grip like that, you
can do all you could do that because
he's holding on. Okay. But on the on the
in the game, you always have to
have to adhere to uh to project.
Does that make sense?
>> Okay. So, we're going to try it. And um
again, the UK doesn't do anything. And
you have to try now dynamically to feed
the adhesion. Okay? And dynamically keep
it being fed by whatever you're doing on
the other hand. And you can you're going
to find you can only project through the
adhesion because we're not grabbing
anyone. Okay. Don't look for ledges too.
Okay. Try it.
Okay. So, if I
go ahead if I have to like push, do you
see to get this
then I'm going to try to have to
overpower you. Okay. It also eventually
you're going to get you're going to
start to lose. Okay? Because right now I
I you're stuck. True. What's your spine
doing? It's it's just perfectly
balanced. Do you understand? Okay. So,
if I just yield a little. Do you see?
So, stay where you are, please. And then
you'll feel that. Do you see?
>> That's right there.
>> Okay.
Okay.
We'll go back to where we were.
>> Okay. So, so here we are. And then this
this one too, you kind of feel stay
where you are. Stay where you are. And
you'll feel it's going around you. Do
you see? So all that happened because
from here I just shifted adhered. Okay.
So you got to watch the the need. You're
coming in and you're like here. Okay. It
should be you come in and I move.
You come in, I touch. Move.
touch stuck.
I can move out of the way. There it is
right there. So, I use that right. I go
back. I can project.
You got to mix it up. But you got to get
the spine to tilt. And the only way you
can get the spine to tilt is you have to
yin yield with an adhesion. Okay. So I
have to adhere.
>> Go back.
>> Not contest. And then you go around me
like he is. And now you Okay. I got
another contest. Contesting angle. And
you go around me and I got another
contesting angle. Do you see? And then
you finally go just use the initial
effort
to
to find it. And so I want you to make
sure his spine is tilting.
>> Okay? So you're going to have some
intention to move here. Do you see that?
Okay. And so that's the one I I'm gonna
yield, but I'm going to yield with with
an adhesion.
Do you get that?
>> Okay. So, where I want you to put your
attention is, is he still staying
straight up or have I got his spine
tilting? Okay.
>> And then I think the adhesions might
show up. Okay. Try it. All right. So, he
he's actually making it easy for you.
He's just going like that. Okay. So,
that's all it is. This is like zombie
zombie 101. Remember we started out with
zombie drills. Yes.
>> So, when you go in, look
like you could do that. You could do
this. So, let's go back and see.
>> Okay. I have two inward spirals. You see
to the adhesion right here.
>> Okay. I could do an inward spiral here
and take this one here this way. So, I'm
on the outside and the inside. Does that
make sense?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. I'm here like this. I could be on
top angle and then I have the X pattern
there which you use one time. But what
I'm not going to do is be here like
this.
>> Right?
>> Your energy's coming in. I change
angles.
Energy's coming in. Change angles. And
what you what you're feeling on that
projection is the adhesion. Do do you
get do you understand what I mean by
that? Yes sir.
>> So I'm loading you. It's right there.
Okay. Which you can use. You can use
that or you can just go this way.
But I make the connection. So look what
I did at the beginning. Whoa. I'm on the
inside. Do you see? Find the adhesion.
This one's kind of weak there. Do you
see that? Do you feel that?
>> Okay. So you could take it around and
use this one more.
You can find that the the little fear.
So what I'm doing here is getting you
more out. Do you see that?
>> And then that's where you tense and then
that becomes projectionable. Okay.
>> But I'm finding the feeling. So again,
here you are. You're coming in. Look how
I came on the top. I get you off the
line. Off the line.
Off the line. Off the line. Not here.
Okay.
>> Do some things.